blumen und kerzen vor dem eingang des
krefelder zoos noch immer trauern die
menschen um die 30 getöteten affen und
können auch zwei tage danach kaum fassen
was passiert ist ich bin gestern schon
fast den ganzen tag ihr gewesen weil ich
alleine die trauer nicht aushalten
konnte und ich hab mir hat gut getan
dass wir viele trauernde waren und und
weinen durften zu hause das nicht
ausgehalten es ist eine sehr große
anteilnahme in krefeld glaube ich ihr
dann kribbelt der den zoo kennt ist
traurig und über die grenzen hinaus
natürlich und so etwas schreckliches
passiert es ist immer ganz schlimm egal
wo es passiert das affenhaus war in der
silvesternacht komplett niedergebrannt
die tiere wurden im schlaf von den
flammen überrascht unter ihnen auch der
48 jahre alte massa das älteste bekannte
gorilla männchen europas nur zwei tiere
überlebten
als ursache gilt eine solche
himmelslaterne die das dach in brand
setzte meine mutter hatte fünf davon mit
ihren töchtern in der nähe aufsteigen
lassen ganz normale bürgerliche menschen
eigentlich sehr vernünftig wirkend auch
verantwortungsbewusst wirken und sie
dachten dass es zu silvester erlaubt sei
diese läuft einsteigen zu lassen es ist
die kombination aus einer offenen flamme
und einer leicht entflammbaren hülle die
diese laternen zu einer großen gefahr
macht außerdem ist die flugbahn
unberechenbar
nach einem tödlichen brand vor zehn
jahren sind sie in deutschland verboten
die drei frauen wussten dass offenbar
nicht die haben eigentlich in guter
absicht umwelt zu vermeiden diese
himmelslaternen in den nachthimmel
geschickt haben
versehen mit mit guten wünschen für das
neue jahr
also keine böse absicht dabei hatten
dennoch müssen sie mit einem
strafverfahren rechnen
der vorwurf fahrlässige brandstiftung
bei einer verurteilung droht ihnen eine
geldstrafe oder bis zu fünf jahre haft